Now let's take a look at macro viruses.
First, what is a macro?
A macro is actually a program
embedded in a document,
such as a Microsoft Word Document.
It typically contains instructions for
some useful functions, such as opening
a file or starting a new application.
And because a macro is
an executable program,
it can be infected by viruses just
like any other executable programs.
What's unique about macro viruses is
that users typically don't suspect that
a document will contain a virus.
Here's how a macro virus
can typically spread.
First, the attacker creates
a macro that contains a virus and
then attach it to a Word Document.
And then this document
can be sent around, for
example, through e-mail attachment.
And then, when an unsuspecting user
clicks on the e-mail attachment and
opens the document, the document
is opened on the user's computer.
When the document is opened,
the macro executes and
as a result, the macro virus also runs.
The virus then copies itself
to the global macro file.
When the document opens, the macro
executes and the macro virus also runs.
When the macro virus runs,
it can perform a number of malicious
activities, such as sending
the same Word Document
to a number of users in the user's
address book as an attachment.
And the spreading itself.
What's more interesting is that
the macro virus can copy itself to
the global macro file.
As a result whenever the user
opens a new document or
creates a new document, the global macro
will be copied into the document, and
that's another way that
the macro virus can spread.